[Musik]
wie mögen
zur bild
[Musik]
ich habe mit 14 erlebt dass man dass man
die elefanten bzw
das elfenbein handel verbieten kann ich
hab's gesehen dass es möglich ist und ja
das habe ich schon in meiner kindheit
einer minute zehn jahren erlebt dass
weiter wieder
ich will das wieder erreichen will
erreichen dass wirklich jetzt ein
handelsverbot mit elfenbein stattfindet
und und dass es nicht mehr gelockert
wird und dafür kämpfe ich dafür bin ich
da
[Musik]
hier in südafrika findet die seit vielen
jahren wichtigste konferenz für den
schutz der elefanten stadt das
engagement für elefanten und andere
tiere hat vera weber quasi mit der
muttermilch aufgesogen
denn sie ist die tochter der
umweltschützer franz und judith weber
[Musik]
wird es ihr gelingen ein verbot des
elfenbeinhandels zu erreichen und wird
es ihr gelingen endlich aus dem schatten
ihres vaters zu treten
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs um webers vater franz
weber zu besuchen
wer hat das präsidium der stiftung 2014
von ihm übernommen
die mutter arbeitet noch mit aber nach
einem unfall stark reduziert gibt es auf
pflicht fehlt das lebenswerk folgende
ältere wieder zu führen also das gefühl
dass ich habe das ist schon pflicht aber
andererseits ich war ist ich habe da ein
instrument in die hände gekriegt also
die formation franz ihrer mit all ihren
kampagnen und und nicht mit allen ihren
erfolgen
ein instrument den ich hätte nicht
weiter bringen muss man weil das
wirklich zu merken oder oder zum erfolg
kampagnen bringen kann die wichtig sind
für tiere für die natur und
schlussendlich für den menschen beim
naturschutz und tierschutz ist auch
menschlich
sie ist davon überzeugt dass die welt
schlechter wäre ohne die menschen die
sich für tiere und umwelt einsetzen
deshalb hat sie das erbe angetreten doch
die konflikte mit dem vater waren heftig
mehrmals hätte sie deswegen fast
aufgegeben
zusammen
wo es richtig und da hatte ich meinen
entschluss fest
festgenommen das war nach der zweiten
initiative brüssel
[Musik]
weil er mir alles aus den händen
genommen hat also noch drauf nach der
abstimmung
wurde wirklich wundern
ich habe es irgendwann so sein netz
betreibt
nun hat franz weber fast alles vergessen
er empfängt nur noch seine familie wegen
seiner vergesslichkeit kann er nicht
mehr zu hause wohnen die einzige tochter
erlebt gerade wieder 89 jährige
patriarch sich allmählich verabschiedet
eine sehr starke persönlichkeit hat und
deshalb konnte auch so viel bewirken
weil er weil er so ein macher und dann
entscheiden manchmal die serie
diktatorisch einfach sein weg und kein
anderer
ja aber das war die zeit wo wo ist das
gebraucht hat davon bin ich überzeugt
und jetzt haben ist eine andere zeit
noch nutzt weder die alten büros der
fundació in montreux
doch ich erlebe sie voller
veränderungsdruck gerade pack die lobby
material für die cities die
artenschutzkonferenz die nur alle drei
jahre stattfindet diesmal in
johannesburg für den schutz der
elefanten ist die konferenz entscheiden
sie und ihr team haben dafür jahrelang
gearbeitet
die größte forderung ist kein handel von
von elfenbein mehr auf der ganzen welt
international verboten
das wollen wir erreichen aber das ist
das schwierigste aber es gibt noch
andere möglichkeiten wir haben noch
andere anträge zum beispiel die
schließung aller binnenmärkte der größte
markt ist china
drei viertel des elfenbeins gehen
dorthin die nachfrage treibt die
wilderei an
seit das internationale handelsverbot
ende der 90er jahre gelockert wurde ist
ein drittel der elefanten afrikas will
daran zum opfer gefallen allein in den
letzten zehn jahren 150.000 das ist ein
sehr schlimmes bild es zeigt eben dass
kleine der kleine elefant der neben
seiner mutter steht
und und es zeigt die anderen elefanten
wie sie trauern um ihr familienmitglied
und es ist eben etwas ganz unheimliches
was man sieht bei den elefanten sie
trauern wie wir trauern und das bewegt
mich immer wenn ich solche bilder sehe
weil die elefanten sind uns sehr ähnlich
die präsidentin und ihr junges team
setzen auf twitter facebook und youtube
sie wollen ihre unterstützer während der
konferenz auf dem laufenden halten
sanft modernisiert wäre die stiftung die
ihr vater 1975 gegründet hat mein vater
war ein pionier damals niemand hat von
elefanten schütze davon von umweltschutz
gesprochen heute ist es in aller munde
es ist eine andere zeit mit dem kampf
gegen die robbenjagd wurde franz weber
mitte der 70er dankbar so berühmt auch
der kampf für den elefantenschutz ist
ein erbe das wir übernommen hat ich
stelle mir vor dass die geschichte nicht
nur verpflichtet sondern auch belastet
so wie diese alte villa die franz weber
vor dem abriss gerettet hat schön aber
kostspielig im unterhalt die kampagne
für franz webers zweitwohnung initiative
war bisher wer als größter erfolg
landschaftsschutz gehört zu den
kernthemen der stiftung
ich merke jedoch bald dass ihr die tiere
mehr bedeuten
seit jahren arbeitet sie mit kenia
zusammen
das land verbrannte letztes jahr 105
tonnen elfenbein die stoßzähne von 6500
elefanten ein wichtiges zeichen gegen
den handel mit elfenbein ein erfolg von
kenias elefanten schützen und vera weber
dass der vater die engagierte tochter
nicht als nachfolgerin aufbaute erstaunt
mich
er wollte das nicht er wollte mich sagt
er beschützen weil er wurde ja sehr sehr
oft sehr stark und böse attackiert er
wurde angegriffen von allen seiten und
er wollte nicht dass ein kleines mädchen
dem gleichen widerfährt und deshalb hat
er lange gebraucht um zu akzeptieren
dass ich diese diesen job machen will
aber es ist wie immer mal dass die quasi
ihre schritte als übrig blieb aus die
funktion bietet vielen die eine
individuelle vor starker widerstand vor
allem weiter er ist ja mit den eltern
war vera schon mit 14 an der
artenschutzkonferenz in lausanne ewig
als tochter von franz weber wahrgenommen
zu werden hat sie satt man wird einfach
notgedrungen von von allen seiten immer
verglichen und eigentlich möchte ich gar
nicht verglichen werden weil es gibt
nichts zu vergleichen ich bin nicht
franz weber und er ist nicht vera weber
es gibt nicht zu vergleichen ich mach
einfach denselben job aber auf meine art
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei der eröffnung der
artenschutzkonferenz its begrüßt der
südafrikanische präsident jacob zuma die
delegierten der 181 mitgliedstaaten
gastgeber südafrika spricht sich aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen gegen ein
handelsverbot für elfenbein aus wie eine
kleine minderheit der afrikanischen
elefanten länder im bay und und namibia
wollen weiterhin mit mit elfenbein
handeln das ist klar aber wir haben in
den letzten tagen eine sehr gute
nachricht bekommen der präsident von
botswana unterstützt eigentlich der
totalverbot von elfenbein handeln und
das ist eine wirklich super
[Musik]
ich bin nicht euphorisch ich bin eine
optimistische person einfach und wir
haben so viel gearbeitet also etwas für
die elefanten muss rauskommen aus dieser
konferenz wäre sie zwei reihen vor
japanischen elfenbein händlern die an
der konferenz ebenfalls lobby ihren
gegen ein verbot
dafür gibt es hoffnung dass china seinen
markt für elfenbein schließen wird
mir fällt auf wie viele leute wer kennt
und wie herzlich sie begrüßt wird
sie ist eine netzwerkerin die in 16
jahren in afrika viele verbündete
gewonnen hat fast alle elefanten staaten
unterstützen heute ein verbot des
elfenbeinhandels
eine ihrer wichtigsten mitstreiterinnen
ist petra bury eine elefanten schützen
aus kenia
wie wichtig ist die organisation die
formation franz weber für sie sie ist
entscheiden wir wären ohne die fundació
niemals da wo wir jetzt sind
als wir 2002 starteten da war es erst
ein traum wäre und ich lernten uns
damals kennen und sagten wir müssen
einen weg finden die leute
zusammenzubringen
dank ihrer persönlichkeit gelinge es
wäre in afrika viele menschen vom
elefantenschutz zu überzeugen
sie ist wie eine schwester für mich
sie sieht keine hautfarben sie schafft
es dass alle sich mit ihr wohl fühlen
besonders gut kann sie zu hören
sie fragt was wollt ihr anstatt uns zu
sagen was wir brauchen
will clarke ist ein alter verbündeter er
arbeitete schon mit franz weber zusammen
für den elefantenschutz und kennt wehrer
seit sie ein kleines mädchen ist es gibt
viele unterschiede zwischen vater und
tochter und franz war mehr eine
historische persönlichkeit er wusste wie
man auf den tisch klopft wer als
diplomatische er strafte die leute
zusammen manchmal zu recht sie setzt auf
verhandlungen
ich würde mich nicht festlegen wollen
meist erfolgreicher sein wird
vera ist ständig an strategie meetings
oft dauern sie bis spät in die nacht
[Musik]
am nächsten tag große aufregung
viele afrikanische staaten hätten
versehentlich beinahe einem antrag
namibias zugestimmt die schließung der
märkte für elfenbein nicht zu
diskutieren
ein missverständnis das fast eine der
wichtigsten forderungen der elefanten
schütze vom tisch gefegt hätte höchste
zeit für eine klärende sitzung
[Gelächter]
es sind zwei wochen absolute wahnsinn
die sogenannte african elefant coalition
ein zusammenschluss der afrikanischen
elefanten staaten hat sie auf die beine
gestellt vera und ihre mitstreiter
stellen sicher dass die mitglieder alle
informationen und argumente haben die
sie brauchen
die kleine organisation aus der schweiz
so stelle ich fest ist eine der
wichtigsten akteure an der konferenz was
den schutz der elefanten angeht
der erfolg kann sich sehen lassen
dies empfiehlt allen ländern ihre märkte
für den elfenbeinhandel zu schließen
so wie es die african elefant coalition
beantragt hat endlich hat wieder zeit
für einen ausflug zu den tieren
südafrikas die wilderei ist auch in den
nationalparks ein großes problem im
moment verlieren wir pro tag 3,60 hühner
in unserem land wenn sie rechnen sehen
sie dass die nashörner in fünf bis sechs
jahren ausgestorben sind
wenn wir nicht jetzt etwas unternehmen
um sie zu retten
in der safari inbegriffen ist ein
sogenannter
die tiere werden nachts mit lampen
aufgestöbert damit die touristen sie
fotografieren können solche safaris
bringen südafrika sehr viel geld ein
was das für die elefanten bedeutet
erleben wir in dieser nacht
[Musik]
ich bin ein bürger
wirklich empört
ja also das stört mich jetzt dass es ist
nacht und man tut die die tiere mit mit
der flasche mit der taschenlampe stören
das ist so respektlos es um mich stört
einfach diese diese respektlosigkeit das
auch in der nacht ja die touristen haben
dafür bezahlt man muss ihnen etwas
bieten also muss man jetzt mit einer
taschenlampe noch nach ihnen suchen und
sie bei ihrer nachtruhe stören ja also
es ist wirklich nicht mein bier man sich
sein
[Musik]
danach spricht weder mit den anderen
gästen über die safari und über ihre
arbeit
dass das wohl der tiere wenig zählt und
sie meist als ware betrachtet werden
erlebt sie täglich an der konferenz
der handel ist natürlich ja das bringt
geld es ist der ökonomisch wichtig und
das ist und dann gibt es gibt es geht es
um die politik eine hand wäscht die
andere
das ist das irgendwie wirtschaft wie bei
uns manchmal in der schweiz also das ist
dass es wirklich so man kämpft gegen
riesige im dreßen eigenen interessen und
und der der schutz der arten steht total
im hintergrund die tochter mit der
sanften stimme hat bewiesen dass sie
genauso hartnäckig kämpfen kann wieder
vater
doch für viele langjährige gönner ist
franz weber einhält die von ihm
gegründete stiftung in eine neue zeit zu
führen ohne die alten anhänger zu
verlieren ist keine leichte aufgabe
ich mache mir einfach sorgen für die
stiftung des menschen geben könnte die
die meinen dass es ohne franz weber
nicht weitergehen kann
ich bin davon überzeugt dass es dass
diese stiftung eine eine zukunft hat
auch in 20 oder 30 jahren auch ohne mich
ich bin davon überzeugt dass sie dass
sie sehr viel erfolge noch noch
verbuchen kann in den nächsten jahren
oder jahrzehnten durch positiv vor allem
profi stellt für die gute sache und die
wilde gut ich auch wieder führen was ihm
geführten und das wunderbare und gold
wieder das resultat zählt das resultat
ist er hat wie so vieles auch sein
früheres ego vergessen was es ihr
erleichtert hat aus seinem schatten zu
treten
sie wird ihm verzeihen denke ich denn
der kampf für die gute sache hat beide
trotz allem immer verbunden und den
humor hat franz weber nicht verloren
ja also der humor hat er immer gehabt
und ich glaube dass das tut ihm gut und
und es geht immer auch gut erfüllt sich
wohl und er ist klicken wie friedlich
hat er hatte weiß ich was ich an
eindruck habe ich das hat in frieden
gefunden hat und das macht mich ernst
besonders glücklich es wird silvester
bis wehrer zeit hat uns ihren mann
vorzustellen
gekocht wird vegetarisch die
tierschützerin ist kein fleisch wie sie
ist auch christian gelernter hotel das
kochen ist eine gemeinsame leidenschaft
es ist das erste mal in diesem jahr
es ist das erste mal und das letzte das
wir haben ein wann überhaupt
wahrscheinlich ausstoß machen wir jetzt
ich brauche mich lieber auf denen sie
ihre schlager und es ist immer wieder
schön zusammen mit steve jobs macy s
gott das jahr wovon umfeld ist das jetzt
das nächste jahr mehr delegieren zu
können ist wäre es wunsch für das neue
jahr
[Gelächter]
sie möchte weiterhin so viele tiere
retten wie nur möglich
damit auch die heutigen kinder sie noch
erleben können
doch es gibt extrem viel zu tun sie muss
eine auswahl treffen
für sie eine sache des herzens also auf
französisch sagt man ja in kuba haben im
herzen etwas fühlen und und so wählen
wir das aussehen in der stiftung ich
oder andere die mit mir arbeiten wir
wählen unsere herzensanliegen und und ja
der elefant ist ein wahnsinns tier und
cs ist ein kind das ich über alles liebe
und dann ja dann haben wir erfolge wenn
wir diese diese herzensangelegenheiten
wirklich nach folgen können und dass
eben das ist das wichtige und sobald man
seine kämpfe aus aber jetzt glaube ich
dass wir anstoßen
auf ein schönes gutes jahr und
hoffentlich viele erfolge
es gibt einen großen erfolg zu feiern
china will 2017 den elfenbeinhandel
verbieten ein verdienst von vera weber
und all den anderen die mit ihr an der
sieht es für die elefanten nun gekämpft
haben
[Musik]